[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: WE PLAYED THAT OF
KAMALA HARRIS BUT IT WAS REALLY
THE PEOPLE INTERVIEWING HER THAT
WERE FASCINATING.
BUT WHAT DO WE MAKE OF THIS IS A
PHYSIOLOGICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
MATTER?
WHY THE CACKLING?
JESSE WATTERS IS ONE OF
AMERICA'S NOTICED EXPERTS OF
CACKLING.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF "HOW I SAVE
THE WORLD."
WHAT DO YOU OF THIS?
>> IS SOMEONE WHO MADE HIS
CAREER DOING MAN ON THE STREET
INTERVIEWS, I FEEL LIKE I AM
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO RECOGNIZE
WHEN SOMEONE IS UNCOMFORTABLE IN
PUBLIC AND YES, THIS IS A SIGN
OF DISCOMFORT WHEN SHE'S
PRESENTED PRESENTED WITH THE
TOPIC OR QUESTION, SHE RESULTS
TO CACKLING.
IN THIS INDUSTRY WE REFER TO
THIS AS A DEFENSE MECHANISM.
LAYMAN'S TERMS PERHAPS WOULD BE
A GLITCH IN THE SYSTEM, A TICK,
OR A TELL IN POKER AND SHE DOES
IT FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
ONE, TO SOOTHE HER ANXIETY.
TWO, TO BUY HER TIME IF SHE'S
UNSURE SHE CAN USE THAT TIME TO
FORMULATE A RESPONSE.
THREE, THE KIND OF GUIDE THE
FIVE OF THE INTERVIEW FROM A
SERIOUS TO A LESS SERIOUS ONE,
AND THEN FINALLY, IT IS KIND OF
A LAME ATTEMPT TO FORM A BOND
WITH THE PERSON ASKING HER A
TOUGH QUESTION.
AND YOU SAW THIS FAIL MISERABLY
WITH LESTER HOLT WHO JUST SAT
THERE STONE-FACED AS SHE LAUGHED
IN HIS FACE ABOUT REAL ISSUES
WITH THE BORDER.
AND I HAVE BEEN STUDYING WHEN
SHE DOES THIS.
SHE CACKLES WHEN SHE'S ASKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT HER RELATIONSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SHE CACKLES WHEN SHE IS ASKED
ABOUT HER IDEOLOGY.
SHE'S CACKLED ALSO WHEN SHE'S
ASKED ABOUT HER MANAGEMENT
ABILITY.
I.E., THE BORDER.
AND SHE ALSO LAUGHS
UNCONTROLLABLY IN AN AUDIENCE
SETTING WHERE SHE'S NOT ON
PROMPTER AND SHE'S FAILING TO
CONNECT WITH THAT AUDIENCE.
THOSE OF THE RESULTS OF MY
BEHAVIORAL, PSYCHOLOGICAL
ANALYSIS.
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS ONE OF MY RARE TALENTS.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
I THINK YOUR ANALYSIS IS SPOT ON
PERFECT.
JUST TWO BOTTOM LINE IT, IF YOU
WERE PLAYING POKER WITH HER AND
SHE STARTED CACKLING, YOU WOULD
DOUBLE DOWN.
>> SHE'S BLUFFING, YOU PICKED IT
UP.
>> Tucker: JESSE WATTERS,
THANK YOU.
IT'S INTERESTING HE POINTED OUT
SHE CACKLES WHEN ASKED ABOUT HER
RELATIONSHIP WITH JOE BIDEN.
>> SHE WAS ASKED BY
STEPHEN COLBERT ABOUT THE BIG
MOMENT IN THE DEBATE WHERE SHE
ACCUSED HIM OF BEING A RACIST
AND SHE JUST LEF